[Musik]
ein 14 jähriger drogenkonsument wartet
auf das verhör aus stufe auch mit mir
gefühle wenn jugendliche mit herrn sich
gewisse vorstellung machen sich gewiss
konzept wie sie sich da verhalten und
ich so traurig macht wenn sind
überrascht sind meine noten ich sehe den
der er so dasitzt dass das konzept auch
abkommen ist und ein ich mag dich sehr
achtbar und ich aus dann berauscht und
du darfst einfach achten noch die meiste
zeit ohne job das ist im herzen sie zwei
jahren marihuana konsumiert und wie oft
konsumiert stände zwei wochen an der
platzierung
wir haben früh wird es strafen spiels
überhaupt mit dir einfach über das thema
vielleicht ist es sein aussehen
vielleicht seine verständnisvolle art
hansueli gürber gewinn schnell das
vertrauen von jugendlichen tätern über
zweieinhalbtausend saßen schon gegenüber
vor zwei jahren als jugendanwalt befragt
er schon seit bald 30 jahren
minderjährige sünder gräberfeld auch
urteile und ordnet maßnahmen an bewusst
spricht er von seinen jugendlichen weil
er sie gern hat und ihnen perspektiven
geben möchte
ivana wichtig
aber der job hat dass man das eiweiß das
einzige vom ksk ja ich bin mir schon in
einer gewissen situation im ausland mit
traumpaar mannschaft wirklich frustriert
über die stadt aber leider fragt wer
sich im büro umsieht entdeckt hinweise
auf seine person zeichen eines
abenteurers und individualisten an
schule körper ist ein mensch der sich
gegen gesellschaftliche normen stellt im
beruf und privat
[Musik]
die heutige fahrt für den 62 jährigen zu
einem jugendlichen dessen strafregister
ganze ordner füllt um diesen 17 jährigen
geht es nennen wir ihn gar los mit neuen
verübte er seine erste straftat eine
sachbeschädigung es folgten viele
weitere delikte wie raub gewalt drohung
waffenbesitz drogenkonsum um nur einige
zu nennen
[Musik]
vor zwei jahren verletzte er mit dem
messer einen jugendlichen schwer
dieser überlebte nur dank grossem glück
für ihre vielen drogen aktiv und
e-commerce-anbieter und solche die das
nicht zeit provoziert hat naja und dann
kann ich frage mich wie eine masse führt
und damit über die person hat kraus büro
ja und dann hat er mich schluss ein
discount dann hast meisterschale hand
kann das gemacht und mache das seien vom
große veränderung was gemacht dann ja
bei chelsea begierig dem zehnfachen
weltmeister im thai boxen darf carlos
mit dem segen des jugend anwaltes
trainieren dass der 17-jährige durch
erlernte kampftechnik noch
unberechenbarer wird verneint anzulegen
bei jedem kontrollbesuch stelle er fest
dass carlos sich zum positiven
entwickelt der mensch sei veränderbar
ganz besonders der junge ihn einfach
wegzusperren findet bürger
realitätsfremd der integration und der
zieht und das erreicht man nicht nur mit
repression
es braucht auch repression aber nachher
muss er wirklich anders als konstruktiv
blut fürs leben vorbereitet
[Musik]
körper steckte den jungen auch schon ins
gefängnis und in geschlossene heime
ergebnislos gallus machte unbeirrt
weiter breite delikt an delikt deshalb
suchte der jugendanwalt nach einem neuen
weg in der regel haben wir die
institution aber bestimmt konzept hat um
es die passende jugendliche dazu und
deutscher umgekehrt sie man hat einfach
sei es verfrüht also haben wir jetzt ein
jugendlich und herrn probiert um der
jungen das richtige konzept machen ich
hätte wahnsinnig ich wusste es auch
etwas kostet aus das kostet natürlich
wie auch im moment ist vergleichbar mit
der geschlossene nie richtig das heißt
reduziert was kostet das im monat das
sind es rund 22.000 fragen kann dass ich
nach dem dafürhalten ziemlich die jetzt
geld ja inzwischen penny sowie bezug man
handtasche unterbringen gekommen mit dem
vostro platter kost hand um sind jetzt
laufende nicht raum mit der größten
organisationen einig nach sehr kurzer
zeit 22.000 franken monatlich für ihn
das ist viel geld aber der aufwand ist
groß rund zehn personen kümmern sich
laufend um carlos mariam ist seine
persönliche betreuerin die gebürtige
iranerin ist eine art ersatzmutter und
rund um die uhr für carlos da für ihn
der nie ein geregeltes familienleben
hatte ist es wichtig eine bezugsperson
zu haben
die beiden kannten sich vorher nicht
die jugendanwaltschaft bezahlt die
viereinhalb zimmer wohnung sie ist seit
januar dieses jahres ihr gemeinsames
zuhause
frauen die wie perfekt was ich schon so
gut er mach schritt aufwärts ich bin
froh und ja es ist nicht einfach aber er
macht gut und einfach wandelt schlechten
launen und sich die klinik arbeitet
trainiert so natürlich er ist nicht mehr
in der lage jetzt kommt manchmal ganz
müde zu hause und dann vielleicht keine
luxuriös oder dann vielleicht wir haben
über kleinigkeiten verschiedene du hast
das schönste zimmer dass ich du wolltest
begrüßten haben consoli körper hat alle
beteiligten die mit carlos zu tun haben
zum standort gespräch aufgeboten
man staunt über die stattliche gruppe
die sich ihrer sammelt sein verteidiger
ist da dazu drei personen aus dem
sozialbereich weiter carlos sporttrainer
und der privatlehrer nicht dabei ist
carlos mutter eine brasilianerin dafür
ist sein vater gekommen
ich vermisse diese hoch reckt er flieg
bisschen so oder so und das soll sie zu
oben kommen zunächst kriegs
berücksichtigt dass solche waffen
entwickelt dass ich nicht sagen das ist
möglich weil das flugzeug sprach alles
was mir gemacht denn die ta letzter
minute sei undank proxy vor mio schlicht
nicht möglich
man konnte schon nach dem griff das ist
von jedem anträgen stich machen muss und
ich habe zweimal zu fahren und ich
glaube bei den punkten vor dem
österreicher über leid geht es mit ihrem
gewissen stück weit wieder das aber mit
jeder reaktionen diskutieren wo man
davon im anbieten ihn richtig
ohne frühstück wenig die eine
möglichkeit ist dass zum beispiel
fitnesstrainer diffus bildung diskutiert
die jeweiligen motive mit lr nach den
standard dar beschaffen und amerika
liter bietet so und du kannst das dauert
weiß dass er nicht kommt bestimmt
in der nur lesen und wenn der mond der
sich die trainiert dann macht er nach
deswegen den nachwuchs noch ein bisschen
findet heute wieder berührt
ich würde mir einfach machen es gibt
viele fragen die straße malt linie für
leipzig und wenn ihr dann geht's nicht
um alle möglichkeiten das du um
wenigstens einen schnupfen
wie schon mal drin und kosten sagen das
kommt mir vorstelle und das ist ja genau
das passt da überhaupt nicht da ist dann
einfach da nicht einfach ganz nur mit
richtig richtig groß raus hält sondern
das ist klar aber skepsis oder nachts
kommt so zügig oder das duo zur wir
bezüglich und chance am montag die sich
rechte aus und das auch nicht
carlos wie thai box profi werden alles
andere interessiert ihn nicht
einzig die mitarbeit im fitnesszentrum
ist für ihn pflicht sonst dürfe er nicht
mehr weiter trainieren sagt gerber mehr
druck macht der jugendanwalt nicht auch
wenn er sich damit dem vorwurf aus setzt
google justiz zu betreiben sind sehr
fixiert mit die jugendliche total hertha
sie ja ich denke wir sind dazu raten
würde mir darf nie vergessen dass mehr
als fünf prozent vor allem jugendliche
sind ganz normale jugendliche offenbar
gute wahl war eigentlich sehr schnell
erzählt die haben den zelten verbracht
wo er auch seine firma die ihre bleibe
und dann eigentlich gar kein strafmaß
ist in sophies rocker das verwischt
worden das sind das möchte mein gott was
gibt ja wirklich folge was ist
eigentlich fertig und man sich ganz in
schweine prozentsatz wo man aber wieder
musste er eigentlich die nur bestraft
dann hat einmal genug und dann haben wir
und das hat ja an die mini vor vorfahrer
schusswunden und darum sondern das
jugendstrafrecht schaffen damit eine
straftat haben wir uns einfach ein
verbrechen und mini bemühungen und wege
von jugendstrafrecht sind tasten
verhindern sondern kriminelle karriere
hansueli gürber studierte jura arbeitete
danach als gericht sekretär staatsanwalt
bezirksrichter und leitender
jugendanwalt lange zeit engagierte sich
auch in der regionalpolitik als sp
mitglied der 62-jährige schont sich kaum
trotz herzproblemen und bypass operation
sehr bewusst bin dann weiß man das
oder auch arbeiten seit längerer zeit
ich hoffe es nicht eingeschätzt
virtuelle hörer schlagfertig ernsthaft
ja erwiderte sie bitte auf und hätte
eigentlich sowie die gutes gefühl dass
wir besser
[Musik]
die letzte zigarette und dann aufhören
es bleibt beim traum alte gewohnheiten
lassen sich schlecht ablegen was bürger
auch nicht los wird ist ein trauma aus
der kindheit an dieses
rehabilitationszentrum im zürcherischen
affoltern am albis hat der schlechte
erinnerungen
ich bin zweijährige stücker und geburt
von ihrer schwester ich glaub
bevorgestanden
und das völlig sie wäre für sie hat den
chat assist queck news vdh und bitten
die dreambox ich habe panik kommen
ältere sind kosten und brauchen dann ist
das so und ich habe irgendwann dank die
kantine zum lauten ruf regen die szene
gestellt dann habe ich christen haben
sagte bitte freundinnen waren also mir
ist nur so peter susan umgang ist aber
nur josef plane sich nämlich sehe ich
das nicht so ganz normal
und darum habe ich anfangen
er fand für sein trauma einen namen
trennungs panik diese projekte sein
familienleben fabian sein ältester sohn
kommt zu besuch im zuhause am stadtrand
von zürich
angelique kerber hat fünf kinder drei
mit seiner ehefrau ursina 2 von einer
geliebten während 20 jahren führte
gerber 2 beziehungen gleichzeitig er kam
weder von ehefrau ursina noch von der
freundin los grund sei eine panik vor
trennungen gewesen
ja das ist schon stress nicht aus
schränkt sie eine beziehung mit zwei
frau richtig schick ja natürlich jetzt
eigentlich ja wieder glücklich ist
anders mittig verliert und das ist
natürlich hat sie trotzdem zusammen was
hatte ich noch vor mir eigentlich schon
recht projekt werden mit ihm
der 29 jährige fabian ist angehende
sozialpädagoge und sohn von hansueli und
rosina gerber wie hat er den vater
erlebt der von berufs wegen über
jugendliche richtet das ist eigentlich
wirklich kommen ja ich bin ein
merkel müsse vor jugendgericht und ja
das ist ja eigentlich relativ gut da
clever oder vor ihm
logisch dass sie geregelt wurde bis
spitze bestrafen kann das ja noch mal
ist ja gut zog sie aber im großen und
ganzen aber nicht egal was ich gemacht
habe ich mich immer akzeptiert viel zu
ihm
die 14 jährige laura ist tochter von
grubers ehemaliger geliebter zum vater
hat sie ein enges verhältnis 1 verstarb
wenn wir wirklich probleme vielleicht
dank der wachen verstand es hat nicht
dazu im alter ist das hat nicht so
normal nahezu jedem land das jetzt
wirklich sehen also wieder ein problem
zu ihm geantwortet ja also also für mich
das wirklich so
aber wenn ich nichts sehen ja nicht
immer wo ich wohne ja eine da aber wenn
ich im alter lassen müssen wenn ihr
eigentlich geschafft für eine chance und
wenn mir rat wird geht er ein rad aber
dann hätte mit kühlem wetter half man
ist ja schon wenn er einfach zu belassen
die sauna im keller ist seit jahren
belegt das ist nicht so rasch aber wie
sie schlagen kann ich aber passieren
dass moskau ein dass sie ruhig ihr mich
seht friedlich
hier ist das reich von über 100
reptilien als 14-jähriger kaufte er sich
seine erste schlange heute sind es über
schon als bub fasziniert ihn ganz
besonders wovor sich andere regeln dass
sein hobby viel zeit beansprucht kommt
gürber bisweilen sie entgegen
das ist natürlich für mich immer so
eines rückzugs gebirgs sie war nicht da
mit den zwei familien mit dem treff ist
es noch ist sie womöglich nur für mich
und kann seine sachen machen wie der
dialog also was für mich wichtig sie
einfach zu viel arbeite da es in puncto
mit den routinen arbeiten
doch zwischen eine darum dass man bis
dahin und studiert oder sachen in der
zürcher jugendanwaltschaft hat der chef
zu einem werbe anlass in eigener sache
geladen
in einem jahr wird hansueli gürber
pensioniert dann wieder zu neuen ufern
aufbrechen
namibia und botswana hat er schon oft
bereist in diesen ländern möchte er als
reiseleiter tätig werden und das könnten
seine kunden seien mitarbeiter und
berufskollegen die mit gelber ein
abenteuer erleben möchten
das ist krieg und sagt ein paar in der
geschichte des autors und auch die
verbraucher dann scheide ich sie ja ich
nichts verbrochen hat es mit den
absatzzahlen nach oben auch dass man
schöne mit 15 biete fahrer warten auf
das grüne 6 verloren aber einig mit ein
faszinierendes und volk das je nach
jahreszeit mit seinen darum ziehen
werden im regen und den wasservorräten
und jugendanwalt oder als privatperson
hansueli gürber hinterließ schon immer
deutliche spuren
haben auch sie sich von seinem weg lässt
er sich nicht abbringen wohl auch in
zukunft nicht
[Musik]